-Thank you.
- 5 o'clock this morning.
All of the airline's flights
were cancelled...
-New do?
-Yeah, she likes big hair.
Pacey, there you are.
We need plates.
You are so sweet to open up
your place like this.
I love you both.
You're late for work.
Oh, God, Mum!
Oh, hi, son.
Your mother and I were...
Just discussing
whether or not...
We needed
a new coffee table.
-Hi, Pacey.
-Hi, Mr Leery.
Mrs Leery.
Need some help?
Uh... Stay and play
with your camera.
Boys and their toys...
If you wanna wear my things,
fine,
they're fairly useless to me
at this point,
but that means
you put them back
where you found them.
Got it?
Joey, give me a hand.
Here, grab this tray.
Here.
-How are you doing, Pacey?
-I'm good, Bess.
I'm good, thanks.
Sorry I'm late Mr Douglas.
My car broke d...
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Hi.
Contrary to popular belief,
I did not come here
to ruin your life
and I am trying so hard
not to do that.
I'm sorry...
She has food in her teeth.
Oh, my God.
-Oh...
-Great. Just great.
My father's gonna kill me.
Oh, my God, oh, my God.
Officer, please,
I am so sorry.
Promise me I can visit.
Only if you bring
that man of yours.
Love you to death,
little sis.
Love you more,
little brother.
How do you feel
about my filmmaking?
-Hi, I'm Jack.
-Can I help you?
-Andie's brother.
-Who's Andie?
My sister.
With what
we've been through
I'll be damned
if we get back together
over your sense
of obligation,
or, worse, pity.
Screw pity.
I love you.
I love you, Jack.
I love that you're
the bravest person I know...
and the kindest.
I love that
no matter what you do
your life
is gonna stand out.
I wanna stand out with you.
And your daughter.
If you'll let me.
That's the Dudleys
right there.
Oh, just stop
your punk ass whining.
School is out today
It's my one chance
to sleep in,
catch up on my soaps,
enjoy the storm.
Hey, dad's orders.
Evening,
Mr and Mrs Dudley.
I was just, uh...
kissing my boyfriend.
That's sweet, dear.
Joey.
Audrey.
Can I ask
my favourite roommate
in the whole wide world
the hugest of favours?
Sure. As long as
it doesn't involve me
leaving this room.
It involves me
Zack is here.
-Where?
-Outside.
The one with the tattoo
of his frat on his ankle?
No, that was Tom.
What happened to Tom?
Bad kisser, H.O.B.
-H.O.B?
-Hair on back. Gross.
Ah, that's good.
Too good.
Actually.
Might make a bloke
wanna invite a bird
up to his room
for a nightcap.
What do you say?
Absolutely.
Oh, no.
No, what?
No. Not interested.
No, not interested in what?
Take care of yourself,
Charlie.
I will.
Jennifer!
I'll see you soon,
child.
Soon.
-Hey, there.
-Hi.
I'm Pacey,
nice to meet you.
Hi, I'm Dawson.
You're Dawson.
Dawson, yeah, I know.
We met before, I'm Jen.
The granddaughter
from New York.
You look different.
I want a request.
Can you please help Amy
find a place to be?
I feel like
I never really quite fit.
Which is why we're us.
I know.
From the second that
I stepped out of that cabin
onto the creek,
I was the instigator,
you know?
Girl who caused problems
and rocked the creek,
and upset the delicate
emotional balance
of Capeside and...
and I don't want Amy
to be that person.
I want her to belong.
I feel
like I never really did.
Jen, you belong.
You belong to me.
Don't you get it?
You're my soulmate.
Hey.
Thought you could...
If you come up
before she's on the dock,
it's not scary.
You did it again,
you grabbed my ass.
Like you even have one.
Get out of town.
Look at you,
big Hollywood player man.
I'll be right here.
I love this movie.
Oh, my God,
what are you gonna say?
What are you gonna wear?
-Did this win the Oscar?
-Gandhi.
Spielberg was robbed.
This is before he outgrew
Peter Pan syndrome.
But Gandhi?
Guess who I'm meeting
tomorrow.
Spielberg?
Get out of town.
Look at you,
big Hollywood player man.
Oh, my God!
What are you gonna say?
What are you gonna wear?
I have no idea.